all right hot breath averse welcome back
to the hot breath podcast I am your host
comedian Joel Byers this is the show
where you learn comedy from the pros and
specifically our series comedians on
skype talking comedy every week we're in
our Facebook group asking your favorite
comedians your favorite comedy questions
so if you're not a member yet go into
the description of this show click join
the Facebook group and you can start
connecting with comics like today's
guest as well as listeners and fans from
around the world so that being said our
guest is the one the only round of
applause for Francisco Ramos ladies and
gentlemen give it up for Francisco thank
ya
ya
ear so there's yeah there's a applause
sound effect going off on our end so
thank you for doing this by the way
now of course things we're having man
how are you as your quarantine treating
you huh you know we're staying busy
instead of worried you know I've been
that's good all the shows have been
canceled you know it's like at this
point I've just been really building
this podcast we are doing like three of
these queue days a week and just really
focusing on what I can control which is
building the podcast in the community
yeah I mean that's best thing I think
anybody can I mean that's the same thing
I'm doing I'm focusing on doing the
other stuff that I that I can't control
like you say like writing you know I've
been writing scripts and writing working
on the sketches and podcast and all this
stuff so it's kind of like that's what
we you know you can't just
not do anything you know what I mean
exactly yeah I can't just roll over I
mean this is an opportunity to really
focus on things that we were finding
excuses not to do you know yeah
that's exactly even I'm like for me I'm
like I'm finally doing like a diet thing
and I'm like like if if I can do it now
there's no way I can I mean there's no
excuse not to do it now because like you
can't go to eat like you can't control
your food it's kind of like this is the
perfect time if anybody wants to do a
diet or whatever they want to do or not
eat something it's right now yeah and
what what are what I specifically are
you changing in your diet what are you
what are you doing oh
it's just I got a friend send me this
diet it's basically pretty much it's
just I mean you eat pretty much
throughout the day but it's just like
protein and vegetables and like he just
got cut dairy or you know anything like
that so like just any dairy or any
obviously fat or anything like that but
it's pretty much that and you don't have
to work out too much just got to do
whatever you want to do and it actually
works I mean like I've been doing it for
like a week and a half and I already
lost like five pounds just pretty much
doing that what do you say but you could
feel like it's like I do give myself one
day like I gave myself Sunday to do like
the cheat day and like I was like but
Sunday I was like I want carbs I was
like I got a pizza I was like just give
me anything that doesn't that's just
fluff just give me cuz it's funny cuz
their bodies like I mean you know but
then it was a good day to go stuff
myself with that and then go back to the
other stuff when this works I mean it's
pretty easy
I mean people like anybody any guys are
like religions man it's like they all do
the same thing is whatever you want you
know so however you want to feel you
know whatever connects with you but at
the end of day it's like you can't
and I move that's pretty much yeah it's
it's big we all want like some sort of
like life hack or shortcut but it really
is like yeah I mean we all know what we
should eat but it's like we want someone
that looks cool to tell us a cooler way
to just eat what we instinctually know
is good versus bad but I could tell a
difference thank you very much when
you're like healthy and you're eating
healthier just like you overall
productivity your mindset or like
optimism and focus and clarity as ever
it really does it really does because I
think it's like one once you do one
thing that and you're like oh I can do
this so that means I can do this you
know once you complete one task it could
be a diet or it could be I organize my
room or whatever it is it's like you
finally got like oh if I did this then I
guess like you know it gives you that
adrenaline to do other stuff yeah I have
found this has helped and Quarantine has
really helped me generate like daily
habits like early in the day like I wake
up and I've been meditating every day
and then I I do exercise which started
out as like a ten-minute like little
thing that's now growing to like 2025
but it all just super incremental and
then I walk my dog like I'm I've started
to create rituals within the morning of
small victories that really snowball
into like momentum into the rest of the
day so it's been super Yakama I've been
doing this same thing completely like I
mean I basically I'm like I'm like if I
consider myself right now like if I'm
like a like I'm a white-collar crime or
like I come at it like I'm a corrupt
politician that's on house arrest and
this is my prison so like in order to
keep saying in prison you have to do
that you have to have a routine because
if not you go nuts so like yeah I do the
same thing I meditate I walk the dog
stuff I don't watch TV until the end of
the day pretty much like I try to keep
myself kind of like yes just do
everything that I need to do and then at
the end then I'll watch TV at night
whatever but like you need to have that
in order I think that's why there's many
people that are like going like get nuts
because they don't have that they don't
create a routine so it's like yeah
obviously you're gonna go nuts if you
got nothing to to fill your time with
you know yeah that's something I've
really been opening these shows with is
like talking to other comics about like
what what are you doing you know what I
mean it's like what are we supposed to
be what do we do right now and a big
thing has been like like what you're
talking about oh I'm writing scripts I'm
working on sketches a podcast one of my
favorites was Jeremiah Watkins was
saying how this is a great time to learn
a new skill so if it's like if you've
wanted to learn how to edit your own
videos learn you have the time you want
to learn Photoshop learn like now is the
time to start learning these new skills
that when the stage comes back you're
gonna just become that much more
powerful
ya know that's so that exactly right I
mean that's why I see so many people
like getting mad about like I can't do
this and I can go to the bar and I can
go to there I'm like you cook you can do
that all the time it's like why don't
you use this opportunity to get like you
said enrich yourself as a person stuff
that like whatever you want to do it
doesn't have to be even comedy could be
like I want to learn how to you know how
to build something or how to whatever
write or read more whatever but a second
it's an opportunity to really use this
to to make yourself a better person it's
like - well you know oh yeah dusty slay
was saying he's been making birdhouses
so it's like yeah it's time to do things
you've been wanting to do and what I
admire about ya your career and what you
do is like it seems like
how long you been doing stand-up
about twelve years now twelve years so
it's seemingly I've been doing it at ten
and
from what I understand it's being just
good at stand-up isn't enough anymore
and you're really a common that is
multifaceted and I'm excited about the
timing of this interview first off
because I'm I have a feeling you're
gonna be going from oh you're the guy
from that thing - oh you're that thing
type deal you know what I mean like so
it's cool to catch you at this point
but you've been able to bridge the gap
but thank you of course yeah
and you're been able to really bridge
the gap between like stand-up and acting
and that's something I really wanted to
get in with you because like as
stand-ups a lot of us do want to get
into acting and maybe have no idea how
or maybe we're terrible so like what was
that what was that process cuz you're
successful at both so it's like how how
francisco how
the magic how
of industry talk is like
well it's funny cuz it's like I always
tell people like I'm gonna tell you
why did it or what whatever you know
what happened to me so and but I always
tell people this is what I what happened
to me that doesn't mean this is same for
you or or it's gonna be like your way
you know your ways probably gonna go
faster you know so other people that
take longer time it doesn't matter but
uh sort of acting I mean I was I mean I
loved acting I always wanted to act you
know I mean I started doing stand-up I
started doing improv and one of the
reasons I love doing improv is because
you get to act you get to do different
characters you do different things so
like that's what and then I started
doing stand-up and I started to
understand but I always loved acting and
acting it was always a thing that for me
it was hard in the beginning a lot
because I stand up why we are the whole
like a simple example is this as a
stand-up we do we're the whole
production
we are the camera where the actor where
the producer with a director with the
sound with the DP where everything so
like when we go onstage we have to do
everything so like we're used to doing
everything so when we go so one thing
and then with acting you have to realize
you're one of a hundred and the call
sheet or whatever it is so say it's so
the main thing is like you have to turn
it down and go down especially for me
you know it took me a while because when
I started especially I was very energy
and like go this and hey I'm gonna make
it laughs and funny and physical and
when you do that in acting it just looks
like whoa like too much like ground
yourself be a real be a normal person
stuff like that so I think that's the
main thing I think that I tell with
stand-ups because you know we have to
realize I mean and so people comes easy
because some people are just more chill
on stage and they just do that and it's
kind of like an easy transition but you
have to another advice that Delia told
me I think Chris D'Elia
once is like because I told mom and
you're a good actor I remember it's like
oh yes I guess you have to say it's like
you can't I can't do the same thing that
I do on the stage on stand-up when I act
it looks crazy and I that really helped
me to realize that that's true you can't
be the same kind of like in you know
same personality on stage I mean it for
a for that type of role you know as a
lot of your acting opportunity come from
people seeing you on stage or you like
out at auditions more seeking him that
way
it's it's well it's funny it's like most
of the I mean some I had gotten through
additions but but and it's not I got in
like a lot but I think like
two-thirds of what I got have gone
through either people see me doing
stand-up or recommendations because
people don't know me as a stand-up so
that's another thing that I tell people
it's like you don't you know when you
perform you never know who's on stage so
doesn't matter if it's three people that
you know that person could be somebody
that knows somebody that knows somebody
so I was like even for like this gente
fie show that I mean you know Netflix
right now one of the produce one of the
creators saw me in a show that I did and
he remembered me because of that so so
that's I guess I had no idea he was
there and I just did my you know so it's
like you never know that's why so it's
good to
know never never doesn't matter what
kind of show you're doing always do a
good job because you never know is gonna
go be offstage boom and how like for a
comic curious about getting into acting
like what do you have any advice of how
we can start getting that getting the
momentum in that direction yeah yeah
yeah I mean I think
one thing that I say acting I think it's
a it's a skill that you do need to learn
it you do need to take classes stand up
um
50-50 on the taking classes Fame I think
I never took her class I just wrote the
I just read a book I just read a Judy
Carter book you know and that's how can
you know that book comedy Bible fan yeah
very basically that yeah that taught me
how to you know how to create a how to
write a joke but to me with stand-up the
main thing that you need to do is get up
and be comfortable on stage by your you
know as yourself you know to me you
don't need a class for that I mean I
think but some comics have taken a class
if you take a class you should be like
one class that you take that just
teaches you a little thing and then that
they don't take any more classes because
nobody can teach you to be funny yeah
it's all the classes are good for like a
like a learning curve you can learn the
technique yes faster than just banging
your head against the wall onstage but
you have to get on stage period yes yeah
but with acting you do need classes and
you do need to take a lot of classes and
always be on classes because acting is a
very skilled at obviously you need other
people you need to do you know you
rehearse a lot so I think my
recommendation taking classes is like
there's several types of acting
techniques you know there's a Meisner
there's stress you know there's that you
can always go online and see I mean I
would suggest take one class intro class
of each of those classes just to see
which one do you like which one works
for you the best because I've taken
several ones and finally I mean one that
that's the one that I'm right now that's
those Meisner and I feel that's the one
that I that fits what I understand it
better you know what it means easier for
me to and everybody has a different way
of thinking so it's like it's whatever
to me as I take a class that helps you
learn
understand quickly especially with
auditioning understand quickly what the
scene is what you what you're supposed
to be doing in the story and and and
right away and also teaches you to be
yourself within that story you know what
I mean like not so you're not like a
crazy but you're like oh I have to be
this kind of person within and I will
say this story because what people don't
realize is that we have to you have to
understand what's your role in the story
because if you don't you might do
something you might be the big guy and
it's like no you're supposed to be the
hey what's up guys like the chill guy
you know and then you might get that
audition you might get that part because
you went in I'm like did that instead of
and of knowing instead of doing the
other part
understand what your role in the story
that's gold yes sorry
so when it also comes to
like finding the balance between
stand-up and acting because like you
said it is a skill that each require
their own specific time and repetition
and like what how are you able to
balance those two and also like I was
saying it's not just enough to be funny
anymore I don't know if it's enough to
be an actor more in terms of do you need
to have your own like pilot so or some
spec script so if you do get an acting
job you meet the writer of that show and
they're like hey I really like you and
you're like hey we'll actually have this
like more tangibles you need beyond just
like the skill set you know what I mean
yeah no I mean you're I think you're
right I think we're in a time now that
you can just be one and I mean but
what I also say is like it's better to
be very very good in one thing then be
okay in three or four days so it's like
if you're not that good or if you don't
like acting don't be an actor you know I
mean don't act aminos like just become a
better writer become a better you know
there's there from ways that you can
always be
to stand it you know when I just be
stand-up and that's your thing great but
you have to also be realistic about your
who you are and what your skills are and
also what the industry tells you because
I think if you're good at something the
industry will will basically tell you
indirectly like yeah you're good because
for example if you're good if you're if
you're a good actor you will get booked
a lot if just even if you don't know any
acting or anything like that because
naturally you're a good actor and that's
what the industry's telling you make
your act or keep working on this if you
don't if you've been tweaking all the
classes and you're done and you don't
get booked then you start going like
well maybe maybe I'm not a maybe I'm a
better writer a lot better producer but
I want to tell people is I look at the I
always put your appetite as an example
you know as the guy that I believed that
he realized earlier and it's like I'm
not I'm a good stand-up but I'm not
gonna I'm not a great stand-up like
Robin Williams or all those guys so I'm
gonna focus on writing and producing
then while he does it becomes big on
producing and writing movies huge and
shows and now what does he do now he can
do stand-up now I can do a Netflix
special like you can always go back you
know the main site so use your skills
that you have to to get to what do you
want to go but also I do think it's a
it's a catch-22 thing you do have to do
I don't think you can just do one thing
you have to do other things but do this
stuff that really that really like that
you really like you know what I mean
don't do you're gonna sing if you're a
good music if you like to sing say sing
for the baby because you want to don't
try to same because well this is gonna
give me the part because that's the way
that's the wrong way about doing it but
if the more skills you have the better
but I think you have to be genuine
skills or stuff that you want to do it
for real yeah it sounds like
self-awareness is huge and just being
honest with your heel so ya help us find
how were you able to become more
self-aware in your strengths for it's
your weaknesses and what's worth
pursuing and what's just not for you
yeah man I think well let's see when I
first started doing stand-up and I
started going to the open mics in LA you
know and now we'll go and then they come
store and The Improv what are the big
ones where you get a lot of comics I
mean people to come by and just that
early on with oh no no anything I would
see like man it's like half of these
people are crazy and half of these
people are are gonna have our know what
they're doing and it was like that it's
literally like that you could see cuz
right I think about it with the people
who I started with and now what they're
doing the ones that I thought I was like
oh they're good they know what they're
doing and they're doing they're still on
it they're still working I know Jerrod
Carmichael is one of them you know I
wish I started with him together doing
open mics and you know and I could tell
right away it's like oh it's his he's
got something you know what I mean he's
he knows what he's doing no and and then
there's other people that were like wow
this person are just completely not self
aware what of who they are or they just
and or they have and that's the thing
you have to be when I moved may I
I even told myself is like I started
finance international business and I
wasn't when I moved to LA I worked I
started I got a job right away at an
investment firm cuz I told myself is
like look I'm gonna start doing this
stand-up Fame but I'm if I'm not good at
I have this job I mean III was more low
self-confident as than high confidence I
was like I don't know if I'm gonna be
good at but hey let me try it and then
slowly like I said people would tell you
hey you're good you get booked here and
you start going this and you start going
this and you can start feeling that
you're but you have to have that self
awareness of like as I mean a perfect
example is like I was used sports as a
fan it's like I love sports I love
basketball I've got why when I see
LeBron play I never in my whole life go
it doesn't matter how much I train
there's no way I can play against like
in the NBA level not even LeBron just
NBA level it's just like it's like that
like but if you see other people then
you go and stage and you see other
people and go like man no to be
realistic I actually I I think I'm like
those guys or those girls I and that's
where you have to be realistic or self
it's like okay yeah no I'm not I'm not
crazy I know I'm as funny as those
person if I put the work yeah that's
something Nate bargatze said on here was
just it's important to see successful
people become successful so you see that
it is tangible impossible
yes and another thing to hear native
awesome guy and I worked at The Comedy
Store and I saw that what he said
because working at the door of the
Comedy Store I would see the people that
that hour that were successful back then
another are huge and I could see their
work ethic and I could see how just even
like for example like two people that I
better huge right now or with the
comments and Sebastian Maniscalco and
and I walk the door they would just and
they still do it in some sort of way but
they would just come in favor ten
minutes before others but you know I was
Sebastian you know I would say hi say
hey what's up or what's gonna you know
like alright okay cool
it's like it's like I'm doing like a
mafia - yeah my getting whacked right
now
but but he just think he will go up and
after he done he said he that's it he
will leave same thing with Whitney ah
leave why was Whitney doing how she was
working on two Broke Girls I mean like
what's about you know suicide and I
could see a al Madrigal Matthew Brandi
if stuff like people that are like that
that you could see them like oh this is
kind of like like you said successful
people that became even bigger it's
because they did their they did it
through the work work ethic they're
realistic they're like I do my stuff I
gotta go do other stuff you know I gotta
work on my other I gotta do another set
you know whatever it is I didn't realize
you worked the door at the Comedy Store
your part of like a unique
group there a lot of people started
there yeah that's yeah that's yeah I
mean I from biggie beginning even though
that was the thing with a comedy storm
it's a she if you work there your
worries because you were funny and like
she could literally what I heard she
could literally fire you if you were
funny like you would go out in front of
her and if you bombed like in the grand
open mic she'd be like your fire is like
what say
okay I didn't go through that yeah but I
did but he was stuff too
starting there because it was like a
fraternity you know the meaning like I
never been like I went to college and it
was never enough fraternity but my
fraternity was a comedy store because as
soon as you got into the it was crazy
like you before you were an open mic
like nobody would like pay attention to
you or whatever as soon as I put that
shirt on then everybody's like whoa
what's up how you doing I'm like and
then regulars be like hey just give you
like what's up you know but then when I
would do the potluck or the open mic
then the people who were above me or
we're already there for that work at the
comic store they would just make fun of
you just treat you like [ __ ] you know
like just you know just [ __ ] with you
and you had to which taught me like I
remember one time there was two guys his
name is Josh O'Neill at Josh and O'Neill
I forget right now their names right now
are their last names but they used to
wrote on their potluck or the open mic
and they will [ __ ] on everybody like
just I mean and this is back when I
started when like they hope the Comedy
Store wasn't that popular so there was
really nobody but they would just go in
and if you stuck with the comi you be
like well it's like well I'm just I say
why don't just kill yourself [ __ ] like
that you know
so then I remember I went and then I
said when you work there after the open
mic you have a spot to you have a chance
to go up it's called friends and family
so then I would go I remember I went up
once and I think they make fun of me
when I say they brought me up and when I
got the mic I made fun of them back you
know right away and then I did a good
set and after that they're like oh that
was good give it up for Francisco you
know and after that they kind of like
they realized oh this guy's good this
guy's not gonna he's not gonna take [ __ ]
and and and to me that's in a way I
liked it because this kind of shows you
like hey how much you need to have that
tough skin in comedy or stuff like that
you need to have that you need to have a
you know you can't in the industry
because how many times you get told no
so sorry so it's a little way you know
some people but I mean for me in work
for other people
doesn't work and it doesn't mean that
you have to go through the college store
to be whatever look at sign Phil for
example never perform at The Comedy
Store and look I have I have to ask
because I I've performed in the belly
room there a couple times but what what
was that experience like for you you're
the doorman you've maybe been in the
belly room and then maybe the original
room but then to get on that main room
stage like I've sat in there and watched
like Chappelle just riff for two hours
or just like see daliyah just slay it
but that main room there's like a magic
in that room what was that experience
like for you the barista I
was saying the main room but maybe
either if one was more memorable to do
yeah the big one yeah yeah cuz they're
okay cuz well actually the original room
is the one that's the most
scary one or the most that one that's
the toughest one of the ones that's that
most because you it has magic okay yes
that's yeah that's the middle one cuz
that's that I
know yeah I mean when I first I mean
it's different because when I first when
as an open mic is a different situation
it's like you know like nobody's there
but like my first my first
doing it as uh as a regular that was
cool because my first like spot so like
you go up there and I think I opened the
show because that's that's what they
either did you open the show or you go
at the end pretty much but he was cool
he but but what I liked about is like
one thing that I think is like about
being ready and being realistic it's
like when I got told that I got passed I
it wasn't a huge like wow I was like
okay cool
cuz I at that point I felt that I was
ready not that I was like great like but
I felt like oh I can do what this guy
when I've been watching for two years
other comics do it mm you know I'm not
gonna you know so so it was awesome
because but that room is well but I like
it what I love about that room and other
comics say the same thing that room if
you can kill in that room or do great in
that room you can do any show wherever
because that room definitely does teach
you how to do how to deal with
everything how to deal with the drunk
people how to deal with that no crowd
with crowd spread out with like
something weird happened right before I
went you know like I had to one time I
think I had to go after Chapelle I think
or something you know how do you forget
inform of that like what are you gonna
do it like you can just do your Fitz hey
everybody's like are you gonna talk five
minutes about Chapelle and what's going
on and whatever so it just is that it's
the best thing to teach you how to deal
with any situation in in in in other
shows like for me when I go on the road
and you know sometimes like if I
headline and they know it's a good show
and then they're there next night or the
late shows like it's not that many
people they like ah I was like ah I'm
good with this because I know how to do
I know how to change to like from I can
know how to do a packed crowd mm-hmm and
I how to do you know with 30 people and
that's the that's the skill that the
original room gives you because it just
is like a
Buck's in gym you know oh yeah I love
that's been I've been I've made a few
trips out to LA I'll usually go annually
at least once just to kind of stay out
there you know but yeah The Comedy Store
is always getting to perform there but
then also just to get to go from room to
room and just watch the cat like watch
who's on stage it's like you go there's
Joe Rogan you go in the original room
and it's like Joey Diaz and then
upstairs a belly room you know maybe
Judd Apatow did something it's like it's
an incredible dude gay that's the one
thing I'm happy that I stayed in Atlanta
and I'm like my whole goal is to like
create my own success build it from my
hometown to show other comics that it is
possible that you don't have to move to
find success so I'm grateful for that
but that is the one I would say that may
be the main advantage to moving to New
York or LA that I've seen my friends do
is that proximity is that environment
that you are around the best in the
business so it only makes you better so
that is like I would say the one yeah
that would have been cool but I do
understand the value of doing it this
way but yeah just getting to be in that
environment around them I'm sure you it
just rubs off on you yeah yeah I mean
that's one of the reasons that I move I
mean one of reason I moves because I
wanted to be I told myself like if I
want to be
one of the best I have to be where the
best are you know like same thing with
like if I want to be you know I want to
develop an app I gotta go to Silicon
Valley you know if I'm in fashion I
gotta go to Paris or Milan you know like
you can't like that was my fan I was
like I have to go there to see and also
when I started I I knew if I stayed in
DC because they see us a great you know
comedy scene but for me was like I was
already so I already has such a life
there that are like
socially as well you know I would I
would promote parties and I would do
this and I'm like I was like I can't do
both it's like I gotta get out of here
and become a new person in that way and
so nobody knows me and that's one of the
reasons I moved to LA because for me I
was like
I started from scratch like I said I I
took I took improv classes in DC but
that's it everything else that I really
started comedy was never stolen oh you
were like I were a great comedian I'm
just going to go do it
yes I wasn't right from zero you know
from cuz I mean but again it doesn't to
me is and that's why for me when I tell
people like do you think we're kinetic
when people ask me you think what can I
become a priest or works and stuff like
that it's like to me it worked for me
because I I didn't know anything I was
just starting from zero so like it
taught me how to be a cop I'm making how
to do all this stuff but look like
comedy for five years in in DC I don't
think working at The Comedy Store would
have been the best thing you know and
you know those I mean you can get into
the comic store is just it wouldn't be
appropriate I don't know for me you know
I love it all right yeah let's get in
let's get into
fan questions here as well but yeah that
I start hearing that yeah I love hearing
that just that self belief I think
Jeremiah Watkins did the same thing he
just he just moved from Kansas City yeah
and just went to LA like I'm just gonna
do this I love that
one of those guys those guys that I
remember scenes from the beginning I
well I work with him in a couple things
seem him you know when he just started
because I saw that stuff realization of
like you're a normal person it's kind of
like be a normal person that is
self-aware of who they are and what
their skills they have you know it's not
being arrogant but it's being like okay
this person is normal you know I mean
yeah literally like don't go like you
can't just go to like New York or LA and
think like I'm gonna be a star in a year
it's like if you have that mindset then
you're not you have no idea how this
businesses you know so it's just having
that self-awareness yeah so let's get
into the first question here from this
is actually from Justin do liard and he
actually we did it this whole week has
been dedicated to like listener requests
and he voted you on member on our
Instagram Pole and he act nice he saw
you in LA he didn't say what club but
he's actually at work I don't know where
he works but he's at work today he can't
tune in but I made sure that I got a
question from him so he was able to ask
cuz he did oh he was so jazzed you were
gonna be on here and
he asks
when someone says Oklahoma what is the
first thing that pops in your head you
saw me you um apparently you did crowd
work with him and he said he was from
Oklahoma and then you did a bunch of
funny riffs about Oklahoma
wow
[Laughter]
that's so funny because it's like like I
don't even remember I mean like that's
funny because like when you when I do
riff because I do like to if a lot I
like to do crowd work but it's so in the
moment that I have no idea what I said
or anything like that I mean I've been
to Oklahoma to do shows I mean I think
some some colleges shows to stuff like
that so it's so it's cool I mean I don't
know I don't know what the what I said
or anything like that I mean it's just
but if I guess it's a great it's a great
state okay that those very different
very useful yeah yeah that is something
that came up with Shane Torres on
Tuesday was like he has some go-to lines
that someone was asking like are those
in the moment or those prepared lines so
he's probably wondering like Oh does
this guy just have a bunch of Oklahoma
material but it was all just like huh
improvised in the moment I guess right
yeah ya know cuz that one cuz I do I do
like I like Shane I do have some stuff
that I that I use here and therefore you
know when I do crowd work just mostly
things that I know are gonna lead me to
one thing or the other but yeah I don't
have Oklahoma
material that I use that I have reserved
for like cry or anything like that so
that was definitely of the moment I have
no idea what I said that's kudos to your
skills though that it came off naturally
so that's Bravo to that
let's yeah let's
get Angela Moore in here Angela Moore oh
she's actually tuning in because she was
interested in the acting comedy
connection because that's what she's
pursuing as well and she acts as a
comedian and actor do you try to go for
comedic roles or dramatic roles as well
I
think both definitely I think actually
comedians are good dramatic actress
because
cop I mean because in a way we're
serious I mean some are serious and
summer you know some are we have our
crazy minds and whatever it is it's like
we can use that a lot in those drama
dramatic roles and with dramatic roles
we don't have the good thing about it is
that you don't have to do too much but
because we comics are already expressive
naturally we already doing a lot without
doing too much you know what I mean so
it's kind of like so and I think and
that when you're starting you got to do
both I mean you can't I don't think
there's a you can't just pick and choose
I mean unless it's a role that you like
look I don't want to do this at all but
like if you get into cuz you never know
again and I'll say what passes you to
where you want to be you know you might
become a huge dramatic actor and then
all the sudden when I go back to stand
up and then you can do your stand up
buddy already people are gonna come see
you now because you're you know
Bruce I was gonna say Michael Keaton for
excessive he started doing stand-up you
know when they became Batman and
Beetlejuice and so I mean I don't think
so it's like you never know so I think
as I go to any role that you can and I
think with acting with dramatic actors
is one of the things is like it's a I
find it not easier but it's just so I
think it's a it's a way for you as a
comic to just be more of yourself and it
still is gonna be more expressive
because already we have that innate you
know persona yeah that innate darkness I
think is what you're referring to yeah
I wanted to be politically correct but
yeah that in a [ __ ] up thing that we
have I was a comics here there are weird
people I mean yeah we are we think we
are that I mean I realize that when I
became a comic or now going back is when
I remember I think some we were in a
funeral or somebody died or something
and my first thought was a joke or
something to make for order to have a
you know it's like only us would think
that way not to be mean but it's kind of
like oh this is funny you know oh yeah
that's our default like that's just kind
of our default setting I've like I've
had my wife be like hey I've like gotten
too sarcastic and she's like hey I'm a
I'm a person I'm not a comedian yeah go
easy yeah cuz we're I were no I got in
trouble a lot with my friends yeah
right now during this quarantine I got
in trouble with my normal friends I call
them normal ones that are in DC because
I make fun a lot and I'm used to talk
into comics all the time you know so
it's like it gets too much for them and
I'm like and then they get mad I'm like
oh I'm sorry I thought were just like
having fun you know it's like but for me
with a comic there's no there's no line
you know we just it's like hey you're
gonna take it you know I love it I love
it it's my favorite
let's see we have a from Canada coming
in here a question from a bowl of Canada
yeah we're we have like listeners we're
on every continent but Antarctica
right now but we're gonna or yeah
Antarctica that's well that's where my
most of my fans are from Kartika
yeah this I was so I have a very niche
fan base we ever you idea fans in
Venezuela or anything have you been able
to hear from there right I'm from there
I was born there but I came very early
to the US I mean I was 11 12 years old
so it's like most people don't know me I
mean I some come in Venice one comics
that are well-known own me stuff like
that but in terms of that public most
people don't know me because I never
started doing and I don't do jokes about
I mean I talk about Venezuela because of
where I'm from uh stuff like that but I
don't do jokes is specific about
Venezuela or what's going on and when
it's wrong because I haven't lived there
for basically all my life so like a lot
of people still don't know me that much
from Venezuela yeah
all right so this is Justin Williams
here and he asks hey Francisco I'm also
an actor comedian from Toronto Canada
have you ever booked a comedy gig but
then also booked an acting role the same
day what do you do
well it depends on the that's where you
got a I would see what's more important
you know in terms of life of your career
and what you want if you go if you I
mean most of the times if I'm booking if
I booked a TV role or a movie role most
of the times are good roles and I'm like
even if the if the part it's a small
part I will do that role because that's
gonna lead to other stuff you know but
if it's like if you're if you're you
know if you're booking like a sketch
from your friends or whatever that you
can do you know to do that day you like
hey can we just do it you know I would
be like hey do the comedy cake but I
don't know anything - but if it's a and
also for example like I remember if I
like Tom Segura asked me to open
recently and I had to cancel something
else or something but I was like well
I'm gonna take that Tom cigarette gig
because it's Tom Segura you know so say
so if it's like a small role gig acting
gig that that is not as important as you
think as opening for Bill burr or
somebody like that that you respect that
you wanna you know that so I think it's
about gauging which always try to find a
way to try to do both maybe hey can I do
this when the next day or whatever it is
but if you can't then you gotta make the
decision in terms of like what's more
important in your career at that point
yeah I think it's important to also like
way like you said the opportunities and
also I've been selective with things
like an example I've used before like I
was offered to do to play like a slave
owner for like this project on Kevin
Hart's Network and I was just like like
like what will this look like in five
years is that how if even if it even if
it did blow up and do a mine do I now
want to be known as that I think it's
important with taking roles and
opportunities is also look like what is
this going to look like in 5-10 years do
I care about this project like like it's
there's questions to ask yourself beyond
just like oh well it says Kevin Hart
above it so I better do it you know what
I mean yeah that's very I mean you hit
it right I mean that's very smart advice
and I and just to add to that it's like
what I mean exactly what you were saying
and I think it's one thing you can
always say use like you never know
what's gonna make you famous in this in
this industry so it's like it's like you
said you could do that role and then now
like I think blows up and now you're the
slave owner guy and like I don't want to
be the slave owner I don't people to
know me as that so it's like yeah so it
doesn't matter what even what role it
doesn't matter how big their role or the
is because it could be literally just
doing a sketch for one of your friends
or putting something on Twitter or
putting something on Instagram that's
the I mean you have to realize that
that's the thing that might go viral so
do you want to be known as that that
means so everything that you do like
always know like do I want I mean I also
have turned down all the roles because I
wasn't comfortable with
with being that you know like know if
that if show got famous then I'm that
guy and you know I wore or for me it was
one of the things like I didn't want to
be put so much in in a box right away in
the beginning because then you're like
oh you they never it's like oh then
you're just gonna get roles because of
that and I'm like hey I don't mind doing
roles
like like that but maybe later my career
so then people already know me and then
when I do that role it's more about like
oh he did it's Francisco doing this role
it's not just this guy you know example
to me is like like the guys
the guys who did
[Music]
Africa Brokeback Mountain you know the
two guys I
mean yeah yeah yeah but when they did
that role they won is great stuff like
that because they're already known as
actors so you know stuff like that
you know and like so it's kind of like
so if but if you're maybe start as our
own that to get Fame may make now that
you were just gonna get those kind of
roles and you if you don't know that
that's bad or anything like that but you
don't want to be put in a box so early
on in your career because then you want
to be able to to do other roles as well
I mean so I think it's knowing what to
choose from one or two shoes like you
said you never know if you want to be
known as one person and then like you
said then you're gonna get booked all
the time as a label no you know unless
you look unless you like that no yeah
but you have to know and that's a Robin
actually followed up with have you ever
regretted any project you've accepted
yeah yeah of course I mean I think every
comic as a or I mean it's more about I
mean I it's just stuff that I did back
early on like just little like that
little sketch things that are there and
YouTube or like that I were like like
why did I do that is that mean it's just
like that I see it now I'm like it's one
of those ones where you're like oh I
wanted to just get experience and stuff
like that you know and but it just
'men do anything you know what I mean is
just like I mean there was one movie
that I did from my friend from that is
just it's basically it was like they
what they did it's like they took that
they have taken and they stole it and
they just did a remake of taking you
know and then I was and then I was one
of the kid and he was shot very bad I
mean it was just like it was a good at
all it was like
it didn't do anything it didn't do
anything it's literally to me I have a
lot several things that I drowned that
hopefully that they're gonna be shown
later on and I can just make fun of like
if I'm like let's say I'm in The Tonight
Show or Jimmy Kim and they're like hey
we have this theme from back when you
you know yeah yeah and I'll make and
then I would love to share that you know
but you know and then also I'd done some
another thing too I did I'm
remember doing like a stand-up showed
that that was taped for a cable TV thing
and and I also remember doing it I
wasn't because he wasn't produced well
it wasn't like there wasn't like there
wasn't that many people in the crowd it
was supposed to be a taping thing and it
just didn't look good you know and
remember doing it and I'm like why did I
sign to do this you know and I remember
even somebody saw it on TV and say it's
like ah that wasn't that good because
obviously again it wasn't my fault it
was there that the production that
wasn't but then it shows that you know
that you're not doing so I'm now very
careful especially with stand-up and
stuff like that of what to what stuff
you want to put out because you never
know like again you can't trust
sometimes I mean you have to know that
the production company whoever's doing
the show is gonna put you in a good
position you know you don't want to be
CMAs cuz you might have a great life and
then you see it on TV or on YouTube or
whatever and you're like wait this
doesn't this is bad this isn't as sounds
horrible doesn't sound good what's going
on here you know so you have to be aware
of those things too
alright so thank you so much for doing
this by the way and I have something
works we'll wrap it up with this but
what was it like opening up for Tom
Segura oh
it was great what actually was funny so
I open with him he's you know he's
actually now started to Spanish you
stand up in Spanish hmm so I opened for
him and
you know doing Spanish and it was great
I mean it was so much fun I mean he's a
great guy he's like so down-to-earth and
he's one of those guys that you I never
even knew he knew was Spanish like he
came to me at the Comedy Store I was
standing there and he just came up to me
started speaking Spanish and I was like
I thought he was joking and I was like
ha that's funny because he has this Peru
an accent - so Inez and he sounds he
sounds well he doesn't sound like he
like he knows like he sounds like he
knows Spanish I was like that's cool
they kept talking and I'm like let's go
and then he told me it's like oh no my
mom is Peruvian and I was like oh wow so
that's how we met and then and I have a
show that I do with other two comics
hiss - stray ho and Fabrizio Capano that
we do a Spanish comedy stand-up in at
the Emperor of like a monthly plan and
and he came and did his first stand-up
set there with us you know and and he
was kind of nervous he was like you know
cuz it is stuff doing even for me even
though I know completely I'm fully
bilingual I'm so used to doing stand-up
in English it's a different way to do it
Spanish because it's kind of like
starting from scratch because the timing
and the quickness that I have in English
I don't have in Spanish yet and for him
it's the same thing but he did a good
but another thing too when you're a
really good comic it doesn't matter you
will you can do it in Chinese you can do
in Russia you will be good because
you're already a good comic and that's
what happened with Tom he could still he
was still funny could still do his fans
and and he was great opening for him
because he was a again he said he's
working on his hour I think he's gonna
take in Spanish and and he said yeah
he's a great guy very knowledgeable and
and I like that's one other one of the
guys that I also see it's like oh this
is kind of like the career that I would
love to have as well somebody that and
somebody that has taken going back and
kind of wrapping things up is about
somebody that's done don't just stand up
but did other stuff like his podcast and
then now he's acting and all this stuff
so it's like he's a guy that just didn't
start I'm just gonna do stand-up and
that's it he's just like oh he's so poor
trueness and now he's succeeding on them
did you did you learn anything from him
that you've kind of applied to your own
stand-up from watching him or from like
even speaking with him
yeah no I mean I think well I think his
his his hello and I like I love about
him and me he's a lot of stories I mean
his hold his his which I still not as
good as I want to be with those you know
like instead of taking a bid or taking
an ID and just really hammering the
details and going this journey and
that's what I love about that he does he
just goes into those two things and and
crazy details and stuff like that so
that's one of the main and he's calmness
to on stage to where it's like well you
don't have to be you know you have to be
so much for so baking can still be funny
and you can still bring and that's
that's one thing that I like but he does
that I also learned watching Chappelle
to you know when his do is two hours at
there in the Comedy Store the fact that
he's just like chilling and they don't
suddenly becomes
one of the characters and then goes back
and I'm like oh that's so cool because
to me that's how we love to build an
hour with an hour show because it's FSM
flows I mean it's kind of like a movie
every movie has like that you can have
like an action movie for like two hours
of action people like okay after 30
minutes like I gotta get that is too
much you know or too much sadness and
same thing with stand-up I think you
have to if you're gonna do an hour you
can't just if you're gonna be the crazy
guy he can't be crazy for an hour you
know there's you know it's just gonna be
it becomes a thing where people go like
I don't know what what's going on like
so those things that I've learned from
from watching Tom is that you beget into
this like it's about getting the
audience into your like
stream-of-consciousness i yes into your
into your to your way of person of
saying your mind once you once they
getting with you then you can go up and
down and left and right and they'll
follow you but you have to get you know
it takes a while for you to build that
beena but that's what i you know that's
what i learn about they have learned
with tom oh that's gold and a great a
great way to wrap this up francisco
thank you so much for doing this man of
course that was great thanks for having
that was fun that was fun okay good
that's and i mom i love talking about
this stuff that's what that's what i'm
finding out is I mean I've done over 200
interviews with comedians but like I was
always in the mindset of like but it has
to be in person like I would never do
them over the phone or like through
Skype but now when we're quarantined I
was like let's see what happens so now
I'm interviewing like three comics a
week and I'm like comics really enjoy
just talking about comedy in the process
so it's yeah yeah we're definitely
looking because I think is one of those
things that I don't think people realize
what an art form and a craft is yeah you
know like we know but the public doesn't
know the public thinks is like hey go up
and do be funny in the middle of the
street it's like what no it's like you
don't tell that to a an actor or a
musician or AB Nathalie you know so say
for us it's the same thing it's like
people don't understand that craft and
the process because we make the people
that are good like Tom Wilbur all those
guys they make it seem so easy yeah but
why because they've been doing it for
twenty thirty years you know yeah and
that's that was enlightening when I
interviewed a Jesse David Fox who's the
host of Goodwin have you heard Goodwin
before
yeah and yeah yeah his he's like his
mission with Goodwin is to like create
more competent comedy fans so they can
appreciate the craft yeah and I was like
yeah we're doing that with hot breath
but it's almost like creating more
competent comedians so that comedy just
gets that much better as well so it was
fun to see yeah everyone thinking I was
like how can we make comedy better so
that's what we're doing here so that's
exciting and thanks for being a part of
it that's right so we're thanks we're
having which yeah we're gonna get um
we're looking to get hey soos is about
to release a comedy special so we're
definitely yeah I'm gonna get him down
here
yes it's a great guy what uh where can
people follow you and support you and
all that jazz sighs
yeah
on Twitter you can follow me at
Francisco Ramos so my first and last
name and then on to an Instagram at F
Ramos comedy you can find me there and
and then also like yeah please if you
wanna
support you can watch the show that I
mean right now a Netflix called Hentoff
I'd say great show that just got picked
up a second season so that's cool grass
and then and then I have yeah thank you
I mean yeah thing I mean I'm very happy
for them me because it's such a the
people that that created the show such
great down-to-earth people in the
producers as well so it's like I'm just
happy to be a part of it so it's an
amazing you know it's great that they
got picked up you know to give them a
second season so yeah but yeah you can
watch that and then and yeah just follow
me in support you know just hopefully
when I go to Atlanta and perform you
know come by and uh you know and see me
live for sure yeah Thank You Francisco
Ramos for doing this hopper at the verse
go forth support this man this guy is
definitely a name you were going to keep
hearing more and more about we're so
honored to catch him at this point in
his career so if you want to get
involved in more of these q and A's go
to the link in the description click
join the Facebook group we're connecting
with listeners and comedians from around
the world so go join us there and we'll
be back with another hopper episode soon
[Music]